good morning good afternoon good evening
to all of you
i'm sure you're all from different parts
of the world here
uh and it's an honor to have all of you
and thank you for taking the time
to be here today to listen about what
the course is all about
uh ilia has already done most of the
work for me in terms of laying the
foundation of
why bioinformatics and informatics
and data science is extremely important
today
it almost seems like you wake up and i'm
sure all of you
sleep with their phones wake up with
their phones um
look up things online so look up things
on your phone and everything else right
so
technology has moved pretty fast um in
the last
10 years or so i got into bioinformatics
about 15 years ago or even more a little
more than that
um and i have actually witnessed every
day how things have changed and where we
are today
and it seems like in the last 15 years
we have huge amount of data that is
accumulated
we have patient data we have sequencing
data from animals we have so much of
data so
one thing i'm sure all of you will agree
with me today is that we are drowning
in data from all different uh
walks of life right so bioinformatics
is about i trying to figure out how to
use this data meaningfully
and right now it's as elia also
explained very clearly that the field of
medicine
and looking at diseases has completely
changed
so we all need data science to be able
to understand diseases
from sequences um and so that's what i'm
doing for a living
i am a professor at georgetown
university in the department of
biochemistry as
sonalika introduced me earlier i
also direct a master's program in
the field called systems medicine i'm
not sure how many of you have actually
learned
heard about that it's a very new field
and i call this a new language
and i feel that this language
encompasses bioinformatics
and this is a language that all of us
need to learn sooner or later to be able
to converse and understand diseases
better
so the summary of that program
or what systems medicine means is one
size doesn't fit all
so uh two people you and me may have the
same cold
and cough and everything but the same
medication may not work in you
as well as it works in me and we are
still living in the panda beach
hopefully we'll get out of this soon um
but we all have learned one thing that
each person is different each person
reacts to
this virus differently because we're all
underlying makeup of our genome is very
very different
so how does that relate to the course
genomics in which labs so
as elia said right there are mutations
and there are variations
in your genome so the way i look at
things is if there is a mutation in your
gene
it gets personal so any change in your
gene
is going to affect the genome in some
way and it manifests itself in diseases
i'm sure you all know that majority of
the diseases
hormonogenic diseases where a single
mutation affects
a particular gene in the human genome
that leads to diseases
there is only one mutation so you may
ask a genome is like
six feet we have billions of base pairs
and how
one single mutation is affecting the
gene
and we end up getting diseases right so
that is what this course is all about
how important
genes are to the functioning of the body
and how
single mutations in a gene lexicals and
anemia
or huntington's disease or any of those
diseases how that one single mutation
is altering the gene and manifests
itself
in diseases so the genomics in virtual
lab you all probably will see the
syllabus at some point
in time or if you have not already seen
that
it is um two weeks
a course and it starts with uh
introduction to what bioinformatics is
and what big data is
and then you you will learn a lot of
different resources
that actually are reliable resources
that gives you all the information that
you need to go and understand
a protein sequence which chromosome does
this protein belong to our gene belongs
to
does it have a three-dimensional
structure
and how do you relate sequence to
functions which becomes very very
important
how are drugs designed how do we get
drugs and i'm sure in the scope of time
you all know rem desi but came about
very quickly
and made it to the clinic so how did
that happen
so all of those things will be covered
so we have both lecture based
and also we have hands-on that goes with
it
you will learn to learn a lot of
different resources you will learn a lot
of different tools
that you can apply to any disease that
you're interested in working
and so then after the lecture and the
hands-on sessions and we'll also have
a renowned a person in the field of
bioinformatics that we have we will
invite who will
actually give you uh the importance of
bioinformatics from nih or georgetown
university or george washington
university
um and who is going to tell you the
importance of bioinformatics
so from a practical aspects by the end
of the course
you're all going to know where
bioinformatics started and why we cannot
live without bioinformatics
in this age and what is the relevance of
bioinformatics in medicine
and how do you understand diseases and
in fact what causes those diseases
is something that you will actually
learn it's a very intense program
but hopefully we'll make it fun i like
fun i'm not a serious lecturer
so it'll be fun we'll have games we will
do lots of things
we will go to your pace and uh finally
you will be amazed at
the project that you're going to come up
with and so i'm hoping that
it'll be very fruitful and you will
learn a lot and
find biotech as uh elias showed or mixed
logic is an outstanding platform and
in my opinion is one of the best
platforms that we have that encompasses
so many different
aspects so you're going to become
budding
experts in bioinformatics and from
practical aspects
it's going to pay you a lot of money in
terms of jobs so job opportunities are
huge
for bioinformatics right now and most of
my students who just graduated from my
program
already have jobs so from a practical
aspects this is a skill sets that's
going to be very very valuable
to whatever you want to pursue in your
lives
so with that i will transfer it back to
ilia